ON "SPECIAL REPORT."
JUST CONFIRMED THIS WEEK.
MOMENTS AGO, THE SENATE PASSED A
MEASURE TO TABLE A BIPARTISAN
PLAN TO FORCE THE U.S. TO CEASE
ANY MILITARY OPERATIONS IN YEMEN
WITHOUT CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL.
SOME LAWMAKERS BLAME
SAUDI ARABIA FOR THE THREE YEAR
LONG CONFLICT IN YEMEN, WHICH
THEY CALL A HUMANITARIAN
DISASTER, AND IT IS CLEARLY
THAT.
THE SAUDIS AND THEIR ALLIES IN
THE REGION POINTED THE FINGER,
HOWEVER, AT IRAN.
I SPOKE ABOUT THAT THORNY ISSUE
TODAY AND OTHERS WITH THE SAUDI
FOREIGN MINISTER,
ADEL AL-JUBEIR.
HE'S TRAVELING WITH THE CROWN
PRINCE.
WE BEGAN DISCUSSING HOW THE
CROWN PRINCE AND THE PRESIDENT
GET ALONG.
>> THEY HAVE A GREAT, GREAT
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH EACH
OTHER BY THE PRESIDENT ALSO
ENJOYS A VERY CLOSE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE MAJESTY
KING SAUL MANN.
THE THE COUNTRIES SEE ALL TO I
AND ALL THE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
WHETHER IT HAS TO DO WITH
CONTAINING IRAN, FIGHTING
EXTREMISM AND TERRORISM, WHETHER
IT HAS TO DO WITH BRINGING
STABILITY OR PEACE TO THE
REGION, WHETHER IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF TRADE AND
INVESTMENT, ALL OF THOSE ISSUES,
THE POLITICS ARE COMPLETELY
ALIGNED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DESERVES A LOT
OF CREDIT FOR TAKING THE SAUDI
AMERICAN RELATIONSHIP TO GREATER
HEIGHTS.
>> Bret: THERE IS CONCERN ON
CAPITOL HILL ON A NUMBER OF
FRONTS, BUT ONE SPECIFICALLY IS
YEMEN.
IS THERE A SOLUTION TO YEMEN?
DO YOU SEE AN END TO THE CIVIL
WAR THERE?
>> YES.
WE ARE WORKING ON A POLITICAL
SOLUTION IN YEMEN THAT WILL END
IN A STABLE PIECE FOR A UNITED
YEMEN, WITHOUT ANY IRANIAN
PRESENCE OR PRESENCE BY
HEZBOLLAH.
UNTIL WE REACH A POINT, WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE WE PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE, PROTECT OUR NATION.
THE MOVIES HAVE LAUNCHED MORE
THAN 100 -- INCLUDING JERK
ABOUT OUR CAPITAL CITY.
AND SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT OUR PEOPLE.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SITUATION
THAT WE ARE IMPLEMENTING RIGHT
NOW I KNOW MIKE -- A
HUMANITARIAN PROBLEM, WITH OVER
$1 MILLION IN THE UNITED ARAB
EMIRATES.
WE HAVE OPENED UP ALL THE PORTS
AND SEAPORTS AND NOW THERE IS
FOOD TO COME IN.
>> Bret: THE PICTURES IN THE
STORIES OUT OF THERE ARE PRETTY
HARROWING.
I MEAN, THERE IS FAMINE AND
COLORADO AND A BAD SCENARIO ON
THE GROUND THAT PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT ON
CAPITOL HILL.
A SLICK OF THE REASON WE HAVE
STARVATION IN YEMEN IS BECAUSE
THE HOUTHIS LAY SIEGES ON TOWNS
AND VILLAGES AND PREVENT
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE AND FOOD
AND MEDICINE FROM REACHING THOSE
PLACES.
PEOPLE GET SICK OR SORRY FOR THE
STARVATION -- THE HOUTHIS
ARE ONES THAT STEAL HUMANITARIAN
RESISTANCE.
THE HOUTHIS ARE THE ONES THAT
KNOCKED OUT THE CRANES AT THE
AIRPORT THAT ENABLED THE AIRPORT
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
SO IF THIS BE WHO HAVE TAKEN THE
CHILD SOLDIERS AND PUT THEM INTO
BATTLES, NINE, TEN, 11 YEARS
OLD.
HOUTHIS HAVE MADE MINDS RANDOMLY
IN AREAS THAT LEAD TO PEOPLE
BEING KILLED AND LOSING
LIMBS AND LIVES.
SO MUCH OF WHAT WE SEE IN YEMEN
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THE HOUTHIS
ACTIONS AND THE HOUTHIS ARE UPON
THE IRANIAN REGIME AND ALIGNED
WITH HEZBOLLAH.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
ESTABLISH A SECOND HEZBOLLAH AND
YEMEN AND WHAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO DO IS TURN YEMEN INTO A SELF
LEG OF IRAN AND WE CANNOT ALLOW
THIS TO HAPPEN.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY,
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN ABOUT THAT.
ALSO SYRIA.
HAS A SOLID WON THAT A CIVIL
WAR IN SYRIA?
>> THE TRAGEDY IN SYRIA IS NOT
OVER AND WILL CONTINUE FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
WHEN THE FIGHTING STOPS, THERE
HAS TO BE A PHASE FOR REBUILDING
THE COUNTRY, AND THERE HAS TO BE
A PERIOD WHERE SYRIAN REFUGEES
CAN GO BACK TO THEIR HOMES.
THIS CAN ONLY HAPPEN IF YOU HAVE
A CREDIBLE POLITICAL PROCESS.
THIS IS WHAT WE IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE TRYING TO WORK
ON MOVING FORWARD AND WE ARE
HOPING THAT ENOUGH PRESSURE CAN
BE BROUGHT TO BEAR ON THE ASSAD
REGIME TO SERIOUSLY ENGAGE IN
THESE TALKS.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK THE U.S.
IS GOING TO GET OUT OF THE IRAN
DEAL AND SHOULD IT?
>> I WOULDN'T BE PRESUMPTUOUS TO
TELL THE U.S. WHAT ARE HER
SHOULDN'T DO.
BUT WE SUPPORT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POLICIES WITH REGARDS TO IRAN
COMPLETELY.
WE BELIEVE THEY ARE THE RIGHT
POLICIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT IRAN OF THE
DANGERS OF THE WORLD.
IRAN IS THE CHIEF SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM IN THE WORLD.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE NUCLEAR DEAL
HAS SERIOUS FLAWS IN IT, AS DID
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THE NUCLEAR DEAL, THEY HAVE TO
DO WITH THE SUNSET PROVISIONS,
WOULD EXPIRE IN ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS, AND WOULD ALLOW IRAN
UNLIMITED ENRICHMENT
CAPABILITIES, THEY COULD HAVE
ENOUGH MATERIAL FOR A BOMB
WITHIN WEEKS.
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IF WE HAVE FIXED THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT, WE HAVE SERIOUS
SANCTIONS WITH REGARD TO
BALLISTIC MISSILES, AND WE'VE
SERIOUS SANCTIONS WITH REGARD TO
INTERFERING WITH COUNTRIES IN
THE REGION, AND SUPPORT FOR
TERRORISM, THEN WE ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE WE PUT IRAN ON
NOTION TO NOTICE THAT IT MUCH
CHANGE HIS BEHAVIOR BUT WANT TO
BECOME AN ACCEPTABLE MEMBER OF
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> Bret: DO YOU BELIEVE IRAN
IS BREAKING THE DEAL CURRENTLY?
>> I BELIEVE THAT THE IRANIANS
ARE DOING WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH REGARDS TO THE
NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
I WOULD SUSPECT THAT THE FACT
THAT THEY HAVE LIMITED THE
INSPECTIONS TO DECLARED SITES
INDICATES TO ME THAT THEY MAYBE
HAVE SOME SURREPTITIOUS PROGRAMS
UNDERWAY.
IF YOU QUESTION TO ME, DO I
TRUST IRAN WILL ABIDE BY THE
AGREEMENT AND ON TO BECOME A
NUCLEAR POWER?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Bret: IF THEY DO, WELL
SAUDI BECOME A NUCLEAR POWER?
>> WE HAVE SAID THAT WE WILL NOT
ALLOW IRAN TO ACQUIRE NUCLEAR
CAPABILITY WITHOUT DOING
SOMETHING IN RETURN.
IF IRAN ACQUIRES A NUCLEAR
CAPABILITY, WE WILL DO OUR BEST
TO ACQUIRE ONE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Bret: IS THAT ALREADY
HAPPENING?
>> I WILL NOT BE COMMENTING ON
IT ON TELEVISION.
IF IT WERE OR WEREN'T.
>> Bret: I HEARD OF THE CROWN
PRINCE DESCRIBE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE CONCERNS OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE RITZ CARLTON.
HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE IT TO FOLKS
WHO HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
THAT ALL WENT DOWN?
>> IT'S A NECESSARY SHOCK TO THE
SYSTEM.
WE TRIED FOR YEARS TO DEAL WITH
CORRUPTION AND IT DIDN'T WORK.
IN THIS CASE, INVESTIGATIONS
WERE LAUNCHED, TWO YEARS AGO.
THE INVESTIGATIONS DISCOVERED
WRONGDOING.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THIS WERE BROUGHT IN
AND REMAIN.
THEY WERE TOLD IF YOU
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR WRONGDOING AND
RETURN THE FUNDS YOU STOLE, YOU
CAN WALK.
IF NOT, WE WILL REFER YOU TO THE
PROSECUTOR WHO WILL PUT YOU IN
JAIL AND PUT YOU ON TRIAL, WHICH
CAN LAST A LONG TIME, AND YOU
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO WALK.
SO THE CHOICE IS YOURS.
MOST OF THEM SIGNED SETTLEMENTS,
GAVE THE MONEY BACK.
MOST OF IT.
THEY WENT HOME.
AND THOSE WHO REFUSED ARE NOW
DETAINED AND THEY WILL BE FACING
THE JUDICIARY.
THE MESSAGE THAT WENT TO
SATURDAY'S IS THAT HIS
MAJESTY'S IN THE CROWN PRINCE
WILL NOT TOLERATE CORRUPTION,
THOSE DAYS ARE OVER AND THEY
WILL NOT RETURN AGAIN.
WE WERE LOSING ROUGHLY 10% OF
OUR CORRUPTION.
AFTER THIS ACTION WE HOPE IT
WILL NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> Bret: FINALLY, WHAT DO YOU
ALL HELP TO GET OUT OF THIS
TRIP?
>> IT IS TO GO OVER THE
AGREEMENTS THAT ARE ASSIGNED AND
THE UNDERSTANDINGS THAT WERE
MADE WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP -- IS
THAT WE SEE WE ARE IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'VE MADE.
HE WILL BE TRAVELING TO
SAN FRANCISCO TO MEET WITH
CAPTAINS OF THE TECH INDUSTRY.
HE WILL BE GOING TO SEATTLE.
HE WILL BE VISITING LOS ANGELES
TO MEET WITH PEOPLE IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY BECAUSE
WE ARE OPENING UP MOVIE THEATERS
IN SAUDI ARABIA AND WE ARE
PROMOTING RECREATION AND
ENTERTAINMENT IN OUR COUNTRY AND
WE WANT TO AVAIL OURSELVES OF
THE EXPERTISE THAT EXISTS IN
HOLLYWOOD.
HIS HIGHNESS WILL BE VISITING
HOUSTON TO SIGN OFF ON THE
$59 BILLION EXPANSION OF A SAUDI
OWNED OIL REFINERY IN HOUSTON.
A MAJOR, MAJOR TRIP.
HE WANTS TO INTRODUCE
SAUDI ARABIA TO A VAST
CROSS-SECTION OF THE U.S. AND HE
WANTS TO LET THEM KNOW THAT
SAUDI ARABIA IS OPEN FOR
BUSINESS, THAT SAUDI ARABIA IS
ON THE MOVE, THAT SAUDI ARABIA
IS CHANGING, THAT IT'S DYNAMIC,
AND INNOVATIVE, YOUNG, THAT IT